welcome back everyone so this is
lecture nine and today we're going to
talk about
bayesian methods um that's the plan for
today so today we're gonna
um cover two different approaches in
invasion methods a parametric approach
and a non-parametric approach
and as an example of parametric approach
we're going to look at bayesian linear
regression
and as an example of a bayesian
nonparametric approach
you're gonna look at gaussian processes
right and before we jump into today's
topics a quick recap
of what we covered in lecture eight
so lecture eight was all about kernels
right
and we we saw that a kernel
a function k of two parameters x and z
and um these are typically two examples
in your training set or in your test set
etc these are examples a function of two
of our examples
k is called a kernel if
k of x z can be represented as
phi of x transpose phi of z for some fee
that maps your
examples to a p dimensional ah real
space
now p here can be infinite
so p could be
infinity and some of the properties
of the kernels we saw that first it
needs to be
symmetric uh in its arguments so
x and z the arguments can be swapped and
it needs to evaluate to the same value
and for all for any finite collection
of examples um and these examples could
be any examples not necessarily a
training set for any finite collection
of examples
the kernel matrix that you construct
such that k i j
equals you know the value of the ijth
cell in the matrix evaluated as
the kernel function evaluated from the
ith and jth example
is positive semi definite right
and basically the mercer's theorem
tells us that this property 2 is a
necessary and sufficient condition
for k to be a kernel so if if you have a
function k that
satisfies this then it necessarily must
be a kernel which means
it can be represented in this way
so this was the definition of a kernel
and these are properties and
mercer's theorem says you know we can go
back and forth
this set of properties is equivalent to
to
the definition of a kernel and in an
informal way of thinking about mercer's
theorem
is a matrix which is possibly infinite
by infin
dimension is psd if and only if
every sub matrix is pst right and y
is and and the way to think of why
a kernel k represented like this you
know
spsd is
this statement is basically telling ah
that
k which you know uh this is possibly
infinite dimensional
if k can be represented as phi transpose
ah phi
of two examples then you have this kind
of
an eigen decomposition or some kind of a
symmetric decomposition
that you can take the matrix uh k or the
infinite dimension matrix k and split it
into
um some phi where phi is
a collection of of columns where each
column
is the function
phi i of x for example if you have you
know phi of
x equals x square
x cubed you know log x now some set of
features
then we would call phi
v 1 of x to be x square
v 2 of x to be x cube and so on so
each of these vi corresponds to one such
function
right that's that's the general idea you
want to have uh in terms of thinking
about uh kernel matrices that you know
these feature the corresponding
features of the feature map that is
implicit to the kernel
are like the eigen basis of that
of that pst matrix right
now today we're going to um and and the
other thing we covered yes uh
in the last class was svms is a kind of
is a kind of classification algorithm
which tends to work well with kernel
based methods right
um the reason i say it tends to work
well with kernel-based
methods is because we saw that kernel
kernel based methods can be applied to
linear regression it can be applied to
logistic regression
where the number of parameters uh
that that we say with uh the kernel
method
is generally equal to uh the number of
examples that we have
whereas with a more classical linear
regression or logistic regression the
number of parameters we save
is equal to the number of features right
so we we move from
uh saving parameters which used to be
an order of the number of features that
we have with classical linear logistic
regression
to kernel methods where we say you know
coefficients one for example
which means in general you would expect
kernel methods to not work very well
when your data set grows a lot
svm was a special case where the
coefficients
of the the coefficients of the examples
tend to be sparse meaning most of the
coefficients will be zero
and that's may that makes svm very
attractive
as a kernel method because not only do
you get scalability to infinite number
of features
using the feature maps but you also get
scalability with number of examples
because your coefficients will be sparse
okay any questions about that before we
move on to today's topics
ok cool so lets jump in ah bayesian
methods
ah so
so far the methods that we have seen
can be loosely called frequentist
methods
and that is because we assumed that an
unknown
unknown parameter theta
which we assumed to be some unknown
constant
right we assumed that theta is some
unknown constant
vector valued but unknown constant right
and the way we go about estimating theta
was to define a likelihood
on on on theta so we would define a
likelihood
l of theta to be log p
of say your data
parameterized by theta and
we would consider the negative of l of
theta to be our loss function
and then we would estimate theta equals
r min
of negative
l of theta and this is the same as
r max theta l of theta
right so this is the maximum likelihood
estimate of
ah our our ah parameters
and in order to do this we
we implicitly assume that theta is some
unknown constant
right now
today we are going to look at a
different approach
to attack this problem where theta
is a random variable we think of it as a
random variable that is unobserved
right so this this ah this small little
change which may seem innocent
is basically the fundamental difference
between
bayesian methods and frequentest methods
in frequent methods
there is some unknown constant theta
whereas in bayesian methods
there is a random variable theta which
is unobserved
now the moment we think of theta as a
random variable
there needs to be some kind of a
probability distribution associated with
it right
just calling something random variable
is
necessarily incomplete because we want
to say what is the associated
distribution with it
right and when the first thing we do
in bayesian methods is to assign
some prior probability distribution on
theta
so we are we we believe that theta ah
comes from some prior distribution
right and then we observe our
x you know data
we we believe that ah the data comes
from the distribution
from p of x given theta
this is generally has the same
mathematical form
as the likelihood function but it is
different philosophically in the sense
that
we we are implicitly believing theta has
having some kind of a prior distribution
but the functional form of p
of x given theta and the functional form
of
p of x you know semicolon theta
parameterized by theta are exactly the
same
right but we the interpretation is is
are different
and now the ah the main difference
between the two
is with the classical methods
we perform maximum likelihood on theta
on on the on the
log likelihood to get an estimate of
theta
right but in the bayesian method what we
do is
we apply the bayes rule so in bayesian
methods
we come up with p of x given theta and
this
is p of x
p of theta given x is p of x given theta
times p of theta over
p of x right and
p of x we do not know how what p of x is
but
p of x is
integral p of x given theta
times p of theta
d theta so basically it's the numerator
take the numerator and integrate out
theta and that gives you p of x right
is this obvious why this equals this
right if if it is not obvious you know
just the numerator is p
of x comma theta
d theta right p of x comma theta s p of
x cubed theta times p theta that's p of
x comma theta
and then you marginalize out ah
marginalize out
theta from it right so this is bayesian
method this is the bayesian approach
right so in the bayesian approach there
is no loss function
right we don't take maximum likelihood
estimates we don't
calculate gradients we don't do gradient
ascent or descent there are no
you know closed form mla estimates
all we do is apply bayes rule and get
update our
beliefs about theta given x
given the data right all what all that
we do in bayesian methods
is apply bayes rule which is why it's
called
you know the bayesian method and
with this this is is essentially
the counterpart of of
performing maximum likelihood estimate
here we calculate the posterior
distribution so this
is called the posterior distribution
right and in case of machine learning
the way we
go about using bayesian methods
is is is as follows so in machine
learning especially
in supervised learning we are
we are trying to learn a mapping between
x and y's
right so the data uh in in a machine
learning setting we'll also have y's
over here
so x and y is our our ah is our data
and the the ah
likelihood so maybe let me let me on
so in supervised machine learning
we start with theta having some
prior distribution right and then we
observe
x and y and over here
y comes from p of y given x
comma theta right here
we make no assumptions about the
distribution of x
you know x's are just given to us
somehow we only assume
y given x follows theta whose prior is
is you know we make some assumption so x
is always given right we
we don't say anything about x's
right and from this we calculate the
posterior distribution p of theta given
x y and this will be
p of y given x comma theta
times p of theta divided by
p of
x comma y comma theta of theta
given x and there is ah
we also make the assumption that theta
is independent of
x and this becomes just p of
oh i am sorry
p of r y given x was something p
of
so p of theta given x comma y is p
of y given uh x times p of x over
uh this should yeah is this correct so
uh
yeah this is right uh p of uh y given x
now um
so we we calculate uh the posterior
the posterior is on theta and from the
posterior distribution
we construct what is called the
posterior predictive distribution
right and the posterior predictive
distribution is basically
p of y star
where
x y x star
so x star is a test example for which we
only observe the x the input
and x and y are part of your training
set for which we have observed
both the inputs and the outputs right
and this is called the posterior
predictive distribution and this
is basically integral of
p of y given
x comma theta times
p of theta given
x comma y d theta
right so this is the general recipe of
using bayesian methods in machine
learning right
so this is the bayesian method if you if
you if you
are only interested in theta and you're
not interested in making predictions
this is more classical bayesian
statistics where you come up with a
posterior distribution on your theta
and you're all done right whereas in
machine learning we want to use it to
make predictions on unseen examples
we are given x and y and we want to make
prediction on x star
of what y star is yes question
yeah so um this the question is should
this be p
p of theta given x yes uh p of theta
given
it should be uh p of theta given x but
because we make theta and x uh as being
independent this will just be that
just p of theta yeah good question you
make the assumption that
x is you know on which you are
conditioning to observe y's
those x's are independent of theta it's
a
pretty common assumption because yeah
a good question right and the way
you think about ah you think about about
this this equation which which which
looks pretty complex it's an integral
over the product of
of two um
of of two probabilities and then you're
integrating out theta
but uh this actually has a very
very um
this is y star and x star and this is x
and y the training
so these are the tests and these are the
the training but this has a very nice
interpretation
so the interpretation is is something
like this
with the posterior distribution we are
coming up with a probability estimate
of how likely a given theta is the
correct theta
right so p of x theta is a probability
distribution over theta
right and theta is essentially our model
right now what is happening here
if you just look at this expression
think of theta to be some fixed
you know some some fixed vector right p
of
y given x theta is like
making a prediction for y for some given
value of theta
right and what we are essentially doing
is
considering the set of all models so let
us say this is
model 1 model 2
model 3 and model 1 corresponds to some
theta theta 1 theta 2
theta 3 but theta 1 theta 2 theta 3 is
is is a full
vector so if some may be let us call it
theta 1 superscript 1 to indicate that
is a full vector theta 2
theta 3 right so what we are essentially
doing is
we are taking the prediction of y given
x
for every possible value of theta so
each of these will make a prediction of
y
right and then we are calculating a
weighted average
of all these predictions where the
weights are decided by the posterior
distribution
right so the posterior distribution is
giving you some kind of
a distribution over your models right
theta is the model right once you know
theta
you are you can make a pre you can make
a prediction for example in case of
logistic logistic regression if you know
theta
we do x transpose theta get a scalar run
it through the sigmoid function
and that's our you know that's our p of
y that gives you the probability of
whether y is 0 or 1. what's happening
here
is we we are the the interpretation here
is we are considering every possible
value of theta right there are an
infinitely many
possible values your theta vector can
take
right and your posterior distribution is
giving you
a probability distribution over all
these values of theta
what's the probability that each that a
given value of theta is is the right
value right that's that's what the
posterior distribution is telling you
and for prediction
we are we are essentially taking the
prediction
from every possible infinitely many
possible values of theta
and aggregating them by a weighted
average where the weights are decided by
the posterior distribution yes questions
that is for this data and let's say one
of these three models is the closest to
the actual distribution one of these
models yeah so why are we going to take
contributions
so the question is uh if one of them is
closest to the true
uh true model then why are we taking uh
like you know the the prediction from
all the models and the answer there is
that
we are not sure right the posterior
distribution tells us that
it is likely coming from this model
it may also be coming from this model
but you but you know my belief that it's
coming from this model is
you know 21 and my belief that comes
from this model is you know
twenty twenty point one percent you know
it's it's giving you a posterior
distribution of
of uh or the parameters which basically
is like the our belief of what the true
value of theta is
so the choice of our prior is going to
determine what our posterior
distribution is going to be
right and in a way bayesian methods are
subjective because you know it it
takes this subjective element of the
person who is modeling right if the
if the person who is modeling believes
that theta comes from
a prior distribution where it is
gaussian then you get some posterior
distribution and therefore you make some
some uh kind of prediction whereas you
know if
all else being the same you just believe
that your theta comes from say a laplace
distribution then
your prediction would be something
different right and this is probably the
biggest
criticism against bayesian methods that
you know there's a lot of subjectivism
uh in in play here that where and and
that the subjectivism
comes into picture based on what prior
you're choosing for theta
yeah so the question is in your can your
prior assign zero probability to any
models
so if your prior distribution over theta
assigns zero probability to
some value of theta then necessarily in
the posterior also it will be zero
so in general it's a bad idea to choose
a prior which will assign zero
probability to some
right right so you you want to think of
this
as so this the the
predictive distribution as the expected
value
of p of y star
given x
x star comma theta
where theta is sampled from p of
theta given x y
right so this is the training set from
the training set
you construct a posterior distribution
right and then you take the
the prediction of p of y given x where
theta here is a random variable
that is distributed according to the
posterior distribution and this
expectation
is equal to this yes question
uh why is
yeah so in you know i guess the question
is how is this different from generative
models that we uh
saw before
yeah the the it is uh the question is
why is this more subjective it is
more subjective because we are making
yet another assumption of the way theta
is
is uh distributed for example in in gda
when we when we studied gda
the mu and sigma we did not have a prior
on them right they were just some
unknown constant that we estimated using
maximum likelihood
whereas if you took a bayesian approach
there the muse and sigmas
of your gda would also have prior
distributions on them and you would
calculate a posterior
without doing maximum likelihood
okay yeah so um yeah so this is
this is uh one way to think of the uh
posterior predictive distribution
that you're essentially taking the
prediction from every possible model
configuration that you can come up with
and then taking an
average of those of those predictions
as a weighted average where the weights
come from the posterior distribution
right and this approach
is essentially what one might call
parametric
we call it parametric because p of y
given
x comma theta is you know
has has some functional form for which
theta is a parameter
right so y given x
theta is generally you know for example
it could be
logistic one over one plus e to the
minus theta transpose x
and because of this functional form
the degree of freedom that we have is to
just change theta
right and that in a way limits
the set of all possible models that we
can consider
the set of all possible predictive
functions that we have
is limited by this functional form
right and different values of theta
gives us different
specific predictive functions but the
set of all these predictive functions is
still somewhat
limited and one way to kind of
see that limitation is supposing we have
um right
lets say we have a regression problem
right now what is the correct
hypothesis form for this maybe its
linear
or maybe it is quadratic
or maybe it is cubic
right or maybe as you observe more data
if you observe more data
maybe it is a much higher order
polynomial because there probably is
some you know well predictable varying
varying uh variance um in it right
and by by limiting ourselves to
certain kinds of certain family
of parametric functions we are
essentially saying
no matter how much data is given to us
we just cannot be flexible to fit all
this variance
even though that probably is not noise
and
is true signal right the
that's the fundamental limitation of
parametric models is that
the functional form of the the
hypothesis function
limits us from being flexible even in
the presence
of a lot of data which suggests that
there is some other pattern
which is why there is interest in
non parametric methods right non
parametric methods on the other hand
are
the way to think of non parametric
methods is that
we consider the set of all possible
functions
right and and that seems pretty
expansive right
considering the set of all possible
functions and it's it's hard to you even
imagine and
write it down on on a piece of paper you
know what that class even looks like
right the set of all possible functions
and and then we let
data kind of decide which function from
that set we actually want
right so in non parametric methods
we generally you know think of some
function f
and assume no functional form whatsoever
right we just work with a function f
which could be
any kind of function
so uh before we get into
do ah the details let's let's have a
look at
uh bayesian linear regression to get a
better feel for
how the bayesian ah the bayesian method
works in case of regression
and then we will move on to non
parametric methods that is gaussian
processes
so bayesian linear regression
and bayesian linear regression
so again in basic linear regression we
are we start with the training set
x i y i
y equals 1 to n this is a full training
set right
it comes from some unknown distribution
and we make the
assumption that y i equals
theta transpose x i
plus some unknown noise epsilon
where epsilon i comes from
some normal distribution sigma square
and
theta comes from some normal
distribution
top square
right so this looks very similar to the
standard linear regression setting that
we had
except we also apply a prior on theta
right this is the only extra line from
standard linear regression
and now
good question so what is tau square i
so in this case each epsilon i was a
scalar
so sigma square was a scalar over here
theta is in rd
and x is also in rd
so theta this this was a standard you
know this is just a normal distribution
but this is the multivariate gaussian
distribution where
zero over here is a zero vector and
tao square i is a covariance matrix
which is
in this case a diagonal covariance
matrix where the diagonal values are tau
square
right thanks for asking that
so we are given this and
in case of the standard
or the the ah frequentest approach to
linear regression
we constructed a likelihood function for
so in the in the
frequentist approach
l theta equals log of
p of y given x theta
right and ah and this turned out to be
um if you remember log 1 over
square root 2 by sigma square
exponent of y minus
theta transpose x square
minus half over sigma square
right and and and uh
essentially in this uh it
it boils down to just the square term
everything else just
just cancels out or becomes a constant
factor
and we end up getting the the squared
loss function right and we perform
so performing maximum likelihood was
like minimizing least squares so that
was the frequency setting
but what about the bayesian setting in
the bayesian setting
we get p of we do not do maximum
likelihood so
you know in bayesian
linear regression we just
construct p of theta given
s so let us call this s s is the full
training set
right we construct p of ah theta given s
using using bayes rule and in case of
linear regression
you can work it out this will be
theta given s will be
distributed according to a normal
distribution
mean 1 over sigma square
a inverse x
transpose y comma
a inverse
where a is given by
1 over sigma square
x transpose x plus
1 over tau square
i right so you can work it out
the the ah theta given x is distributed
according to the correct way to write
this would be
theta given s
is distributed according to a normal
distribution a multivariate gaussian
with this being a mean vector
and this being the covariance vector
where a a has this form this question
is
so is the question is p of
theta given x comma y
equal to p of
theta given y uh
in in general no ah because independence
may or may not change once once you
condition on you know extra variables
right yeah in general this is not true
was there a question yes
so this is uh an arrow over y which says
it's a
it's a vector
yes this is from the from the our
training set this is
this y right and this looks a little
cryptic maybe we can
simplify this a little further so
right if i bring in
bring in a over here so this is going to
be
x transpose x
plus because it has
an inverse x transpose
x plus
a is one over square okay that goes on
square over
what do we have here so here we have
a normal distribution where the mean
over here
has this form and some variance and you
might recognize that
this looks looks you know
very similar to the normal equations
right in the normal equations we had
x transpose x inverse
x transpose y
right this looks very similar to the
normal equation except there is a small
an extra diagonal matrix that is being
added to
x transpose x right and
if you i think somebody asked the
question when we were deriving the
normal equation
you know how did we invert x transpose x
what if it is not invertible
right and one answer is over here
in bayesian methods assuming
ah prior on our theta to have
some tau square and some
noise epsilon square we
we get this extra diagonal matrix that
is added to x transpose x
and you might remember if you take a
positive definite matrix or any matrix
in general
and if you add a diagonal matrix then
you are essentially
increasing the eigen values of that
matrix
by the corresponding diagonal terms
right
which means now even if there were some
eigen values that were 0
by adding this diagonal matrix you are
essentially making all of them nonzero
and that makes it inverting
right so this is also called
regularization
we're probably going to see this in in
the context of regularization as well
adding this uh our term is effectively
equivalent to regularizing our
uh our model right and
well maybe this is a giveaway but this
you know
this this observation is probably going
to solve a big chunk of one of your
homework problems
in your next homework but that's fine um
so
the the theta given s in the bayesian
setting
is now a distribution that is
centered around this value which is very
close to the maximum likelihood estimate
and has some some some variance over
here
and so this was the posterior
and next we construct the posterior
predictive distribution
the the kind of mental map you need to
have is calculating the posterior
is like fitting a model even though we
are not doing gradient ascent
you know calculating the posterior is
like
somewhat similar to estimating your uh
maximum likelihood estimates
and calculating your posterior
predictive distribution
is is is is like calculating the
function which
will make predictions on your new data
and in case of
the frequency method there wasn't a
distinction between the two
but in invasion methods there is there
is a distinction yes
a justification for this so this has
quite a lot
of algebra that i don't want to go into
you know you can just you know uh
just believe me that if you work out the
algebra you're going to get this form
the uh apply base rule to calculate the
posterior
yes question
so if uh
so the question is in in the posterior
predictive distribution
so this is y star
right so in the in the for in the
posterior predictive distribution
the setting is that you're given the
training set x and y
right and on new examples you only know
x you need to make a prediction on them
right you don't know what it is right
and for that we uh we
we estimated by this probability
distribution
yeah so this will give us a probability
distribution over y star
and if you want a point estimate it is
quite common to take the expectation of
this distribution as
as the if you want to make a point
prediction for y
a lot of times um we want just point
estimates
to make a prediction and in those cases
it's you know it's it's uh
it's normal to take this distribution
and then take yet another
expectation on it as our y hat as a
point estimate
of the predictive y distribution
and in many other cases you actually
want to
hold on to the full predictive
distribution to know what is the
uncertainty you have
in making that prediction right if if
you have the full predictive
distribution for y star
and if that prediction has low variance
if it's kind of concentrated then
it generally means your model is pretty
confident of what the value is
whereas if it's you know if it has a
high variance it means your model is
less confident
which which which brings to a good point
so
one of the the fundamental ah
points about bayesian approaches is that
bayesian approaches are used for
estimating uncertainties
right in maximum likelihood estimation
we got a point estimate for theta hat
ah you know the parameters but there was
no
uncertainty estimation that came along
with it right
generally if you have a lot of data you
should expect your estimate theta hat
to be you know to have more confidence
in that estimate similarly if your data
was small
you should expect you know less
confidence in your estimate
of theta and frequency methods don't
give you that
you know confidence estimation whereas
with bayesian approaches
we are estimating theta given s and what
you will see is that
if you have a lot of data the posterior
distribution
will be more peaked on certain values of
theta
right and if you if you have less data
then your posterior distribution will be
more
spread out and similarly from
while making predictions on y star on x
star
if you have a if your posterior
distribution is is pretty confident
is pretty peak and if x star
is in the region where your training set
more or less
was uh where you got him from then your
predictions will also be pretty
confident
though p of y y given x will also be
pretty uh concentrated
whereas if your point is far away from
where your training set was then
naturally with you know the posterior
prediction distribution will also have a
high variance that's that's one of the
benefits of
bayesian approaches because you get
uncertainty estimates for free because
you're estimating the full
distribution of parameters and and
predictions
yes
so the likelihood function appears in
the bayesian uh bayesian method
uh so p of theta given s
theta given s is
p of you know s given theta times
p of theta over p of
s so this is your likelihood function
like in your frequent
approach you can still look at the
confidence intervals right
like you can look at the likelihood
function
you can say that you are sure about your
production yeah so in in frequent
approaches sure so you can get
confidence uh intervals on on
on theta but the the theory is much more
well developed for bayesian approaches
um uh especially you know it's it's um
yeah the theory is more well developed
for bayesian approaches for getting
uncertainty
estimates and uh the conf the the way
you interpret a confidence interval is
also
pretty different from the the variance
over here
so um the confidence interval what you
get from a frequent
approach tells you if you were to repeat
this
experiment supposing you have a 95
confidence interval right that
confidence interval tells you
if you repeat this experiment you know
an infinite number of times
then 95 of those experiments
will give you a theta hat in this
interval it is not telling you
that your estimate of theta hat lies in
that interval with 95
probability right whereas with this
you're getting that you know it tells
you
you know what what probability the the
true theta
uh what is the probability of the true
theta lying in some interval given by
this right so that's the difference
between ah confidence intervals
and this yes question um
is that true what's the question again
we have the distribution over here
distribution over theta a inverse is the
variance of our
given s distribution yeah so
am i right saying that we need to
differentiate like
find the minimum of a inverse
so so the question is should we
differentiate and optimize this a to get
low
low variance so here there is no
optimization going on
there is no loss function there is no
gradient descent there is no
optimization going on everywhere all we
are doing
is conditioning we condition on this and
use
the the bayes rule to construct
a distribution and what we get is what
we get
right it's very different from the
frequentist approach frequent
disapproach we are minimizing some kind
of a loss
or maximizing some kind of a likelihood
to get estimates of your theta over here
we just apply bayes rule and we get what
we get
we wish that variance is low and the the
way the variance was
will will be low is if you have a good
amount of data right if you if you have
a lot of data then
you know this will naturally be low
right all right so moving on so the
posterior predictive distribution
which is is essentially y star given
x star comma s
follows a normal distribution of 1 over
sigma square
x plus transpose
a a inverse
x transpose y
comma x star transpose
a inverse x star
plus sigma square
right again this looks a little cryptic
but you know it's it's you know we can
we can still kind of break it down and
make sense of it
what's happening here is
we had a distribution for theta which
was some normal distribution
now if you have um if you have a
distribution
theta which which is normal
with some mean mu and covariance sigma
where mu here is this and
sigma is this then
x transpose theta this is just a
property of gaussians
is also normal with mean
mu transpose x and variance
x transpose sigma
x and this is just a property of
gaussians
right and now we have our theta to have
you know some normal distribution and to
make a prediction
here x star you know take x star and we
when we dot product
we take a dot product with with theta
because that's what linear regression
does
and that gives us this expression where
this expression is just
like x transpose mu where mu is this
dot this with x star and you get this
and the covariance is
is this basically take a inverse
and take a inverse and
and and calculate the
and calculate the quadratic form with x
star
just like this and then we add this
extra sigma square
because this is the posterior predictive
distribution of y
star because y star the object now the
the y value that you might observe
has the same will have the same noise
embedded in it in the test example as
well so
that so to account for what the possible
y star you might observe for the test
example you want to account for the
extra
extra variance and you're adding that
variance because of
and you add the variance because of the
iid assumption right so yeah so this
this might look
pretty complex but it is it follows
pretty directly from theta transpose x
theta theta given theta given s
and again even this which looks cryptic
is actually very similar to the estimate
that we get from the normal equation
with some regularization term that comes
in this question
yeah so theta is what we have
so right and and s is uh x uh
yeah so this is uh we have the extra
extra
s so if theta has this distribution
then y star y star
is equal to this theta transpose x will
have this distribution
right so p of so y star given x
x star and s is basically the posterior
transformed in this way
good question is this clear
right yeah so this is this is just an
example of how you would
ah apply a bayesian method for linear
regression and this is called bayesian
linear regression
right it it has a few more terms and
identities compared to the standard
normal
equations from the frequency method but
you get
you know uncertainty estimates by doing
this extra extra calculation
any questions before we move on to
gaussian processes
yes questions
yeah so this would be
the the mean and y star
equals y hat plus epsilon star
right yeah good point yeah so this extra
epsilon
accounts for this extra plus
sigma square thank you
so in general bayesian methods tend to
be
heavy utilizers of probability theory
because all what you are doing is taking
probability distributions
and conditioning them to apply bayes
rule and that's about it that's all what
we what you do in invasion methods
you assign everything a prior
probability
and then you observe some and
depending on what you observe you
condition those probabilities on based
on what you observe
and you update the beliefs of the
unknown and here the unknown could be
your model parameters it could be
the unknown labels of new test examples
but you follow the same recipe you
assign a prior probability
to everything you observe something
and based on the observation you update
your prior probabilities
to a posterior probability by
conditioning and you're using the bayes
rule to do that
yes
yeah but here x itself is transposed so
mu transpose x is x transpose y
your x is transposed x star is
transposed rather
so the question is how is this x
transpose x star transpose of this
right so so um
add an x theta star transpose and leave
it as it is and this is a scalar just
move it out and you get that
all right gaussian processes
before we jump into gaussian processes
it's probably a good time to again
remind ourselves of
you know some of the basics of
functional analysis that we saw earlier
on
right in functional analysis we saw this
relation between vectors
and functions
right now mentally it is
the same relation between vectors and
functions
that exist between multivariate
gaussians
and gaussian processes
right so the multivariate gaussians
are defined on vectors
and gaussian processes are defined on
functions
and it is the same it's in fact exactly
the same
same relations how of how
vectors and functions are related that
multivariate gaussians are related to
gaussian processes right and
start off gaussian process let us review
some
properties of the multivariate gaussian
distribution
so
properties of multivariate
gaussians
and also ah
for you to kind of expect what's to come
the functions over which we are going to
define gaussian processes
is going to be our hypothesis function
right so the so the the idea to have in
mind
is that the way we ex the way we
uh went from vectors to functions we can
make the same leap from multivariate
gaussians to gaussian processes
as probability distribution over
functions and the functions over which
we want to define gaussian processes
are our hypothesis functions with with
which we want to make predictions
right so first property of
ah gaussians is normalization
that is integral with respect to x
p of x
mu sigma is equal to 1
where we are integrating over the full
vector space so if you
integrate out everything you get you get
and this is just a fact of probability
and supposing we have a vector
x equals x a
x b right
which has a mean
let us say this is called a normal
distribution
vector mu a
mu b
and covariance sigma
a a sigma a b
sigma b a sigma b
b
where you call this mu in this sigma
with this we have the second property of
marginalization
so for marginalization given ah
given a probability distribution that
way
so p of x a
is equal to integrate out x
b from p of
x
mu sigma
d xb
so you take the full probability
distribution
and you integrate out only a few
components
integrate of just x b and you get
p of x a and p of x a will be
normal with mean mu
a and covariance
sigma a
more generally if you have a
vector x equal to x one
x two x d
and if this distributed according to a
normal distribution
with mu one
mu two mu d
and covariance
sigma one one until sigma
one d sigma
d one sigma
d d
right and if you want to estimate the
marginal
by integrating out say x two lets say we
want to marginalize out only x two
the nice property about gaussians is
that
by performing this over x two
the normal distribution that you end up
getting the distribution that you end up
getting will also be normal
with just the corresponding
entries related to mu taken out right
that's a very nice property of gaussians
so if you if you're not if you
marginalize out x2
then you get a mean the
the marginalized distribution will have
a mean vector
with just that component removed and the
covariance will have
that corresponding grow and column
remote right that's a very nice property
about multivariate gaussians
marginalizing is super easy right just
take off
the things that you want to marginalize
and you get you get
the right answer
third thing is conditioning
so in the same setting if you have x a
and um
x as you know um having two parts
x a and x b in this example a and b are
not necessarily scalars they're just you
know sub
vectors vectors with you know they can
have multiple components
so p of
r x a given x b
given x b is a normal distribution
with mean mu a
plus sigma
a b
sigma b b inverse
times x
b minus
mu b
this is a scary looking expression but
you know let's let's let's
uh let's analyze it
minus sigma
a b sigma
b b inverse sigma b
a all right
wow this looks this looks pretty pretty
scary but it's actually
not not as complex as as you might uh it
might appear at first
now to kind of understand this a little
more let's look at a case where
you know x a and x b are scalars right
so if you have um suppose we have
let's say a normal vector a
b
as normal with mu a
mu b
and covariance sigma
a square
rho sigma a sigma b
draw rho
sigma a sigma b
and sigma b square
right any covariance matrix can be
represented as this so take the
diagonals take the square roots
and you can write the covariance terms
as
the correlation coefficient times the
standard deviations of the two right so
that's just that this is the definition
of covariance
right so let's see what what
conditioning
looks like ah in case of this right so
a given b is now
according to this formula a normal
distribution
with mean
mu a plus sigma a b
sigma a b is just rho sigma a
sigma b times sigma bb inverse
so that is divided by sigma b
square times x b x b
is b
minus mu b is just
mu b right comma
sigma a that's just sigma a
square minus sigma a b
that's rho a rho sigma a
rho sigma a sigma b times of
sigma bb inverse that's divided by sigma
v
square times sigma ba that's again
rho rho sigma a
sigma b right we can simplify this
further
so this is the same as normal mu
a plus we can cancel
ah one sigma b here so you get rho
or sigma
a times rho
of b minus mu
b over sigma
comma sigma a
square times so one sigma b
second sigma b
right and this is minus rho
square sigma a square
okay and this i'm going to just write it
as
sigma square times one minus rho
right so now its its much simpler so
what this is basically saying is
if we have a gaussian distribution over
two variables
and we observe one of them b
to have some specific value
then what what's happening here
if you take b divided by mu by its mean
and
subtract its mean and divide by its
standard deviation this is like the z
value of
of b right so this
this is the z value of b take the z
value of b
and multiply it by the correlation
coefficient
and then retransform it back into a
right multiplied by sigma a
and add mu a right take b
get it down to this uh the z value
transform it
using the correlation coefficient and
then rescale it back
into a's range
right and what is happening here
take a by observing b
the variance of a reduces by a factor of
1 minus rho square
where rho is how much a and b are
correlated
this
the question so rho is the correlation
coefficient
so the correlation coefficient is um
so basically so basically uh
covariance equals rho
times
rho times the the standard deviation
of a times standard deviation of
of b this is also called the pearson
correlation coefficient it's the same
thing
just the correlation coefficient how how
well are they correlated so
if you have a a gaussian variable
that looks like this then you have a
positive correlation because the higher
the value
of one variable the more likely the
second one is also higher
if it is like this then it has a
negative correlation if it's a perfect
sphere then there is zero correlation
right it's telling you how much
information of a
lies in b by observing b how much can
you learn about a
right so yeah this is basically what
conditioning is doing and this
is the you can think of this as the
multivariate version of
of this right so this is just
um calculating like the z value of
of the b vector and then rescaling it
back into the a's
scale and over here from the variance of
a you're subtracting
away some some variance basically you're
gaining information by observing b
right and and this is the same as
as this but just a multivariate version
of this
right and if you're if you're
if you've done some advanced linear
algebra this term what you see here is
also called the sure complement
but if you do not know what that is you
know it's not necessary but if you know
you know this basically the sure
complement of
ah of a all right and then we have one
more property which is
the sum of two independent gaussian
variables so if you have
x distributed as mu one
sigma one y
as mu 2 sigma 2
then x plus y is just weird as a normal
mu 1 plus mu 2 and sigma 1
plus sigma 2.
right and this is ah
fourth property summation
now with these properties believe it or
not we are more than halfway into
gaussian processes
you're just going to apply them
and derive gaussian processes
of these properties the one that looks
the scariest is probably the
conditioning
property and you can make it i guess
you can approach it or make it less
scary by seeing the analogy to the two
variable
to the two uh variable case and just
believe that that monstrous expression
is
is just a multivariate generalization of
that
yeah question
property three how do you go about
proving that uh i would say that's
beyond the scope of this course you know
just take it for granted
and and you can so there's a there is a
book
called if you're interested it's called
gaussian processes for machine learning
and i would i would point you to that
there is also some
notes that i have linked to in in
in the syllabus page and it has an
appendix where there's a proof for that
so
right so gaussian process
so in gaussian processes ah
what we want to do is so let me try to
draw
an analogy with with multiple
multivariate gaussian
and
gaussian process
right in case of the multivariate
gaussian we had
say y one y two
y d
according to some normal
with mean mu one mu two
mu d
and some some covariance
now in gaussian processes what we
instead have is
a function f
distributed according to what we call as
a gp
over a mean function m
and
a kernel k
right so this is you know a direct
analogy between
multivariate gaussians and gaussian
processes
in multivariate gaussian we had a vector
which had a corresponding
mean vector and a covariance matrix
in a gaussian process we have functions
distributed according to a mean function
and some kernel right so there is a
direct one to one mapping between
positive definite matrices and kernel
functions
right the
and here you are now going to use the
properties you know 1 2 3 4
to derive gaussian process for machine
learning
or gaussian process regression in a
pretty straightforward way
right now as you might remember
um
in vectors we index them
with some index and the corresponding
thing
to do with functions is to evaluate a
function at some input
right so you can think of this as a
vector
you know which is basically
the set of all evaluated so f of
x 1 f of x
to basically every possible input
for that function will have a position
you know that's the mental picture to
have that's not the right definition but
it's a very good mental picture to have
and the value evaluated by the function
is the value of this
infinitely long vector at that position
right so
where you had indices you have inputs
right and now we are going to use
the conditioning property and the
marginalization property
of ah of of gaussian ah
gaussian vectors and
limit ourselves to just
those elements that exist in our
training set
and to the test example that we want to
make a prediction on
right so this means if we
marginalize out
all
[Music]
irrelevant examples
so basically examples
not in training
and not in test
right then we basically get
something that looks like this
f of x 1
f of x n
and then let us call f of x
star 1 until
f of x star
n star
right the set of all examples in our
training set
the set of all examples in our test set
and we are going to assume that the
gaussian process
has a mean 0
so most of the times we assume the mean
function to be
just
a zero function
right times
the kernel function evaluated
right the kernel function evaluated on
the set of these examples so this gives
us
the kernel matrix just like how we saw
in the case of
of the mercer's theorem that the
uh you take you take a kernel function
and evaluate it on a set of points
to construct a kernel matrix then that
kernel matrix is positive definite
similarly here we evaluate
k of in this case x
1 x 1
and so on k of
x star 1
or n star
let me write this more clearly okay off
right and mercer's theorem tells us that
this will be positive semi definite
and so this is a valid multivariate
gaussian distribution this question of
the common matrix
no it need not so so is is
uh should each of these be uh non-zero
no they need not be nonzero they can be
positive
no they can be negative some elements
can be negative if you have
yes every sub matrix has to be positive
definite so what's the meaning of sub
matrix that's a good question so
if you have a matrix
let us say it has n rows and n columns
now choose a few index values
let us say 2 and 7 right
and extract house
rows 2 and 7 into 7 intersected with
column 2 and 7.
these 4 make a sub matrix
so in order to reduce it to a so a sub
matrix of size 1
that can only be the diagonal values
right so row 2 and column 7 will not
give you a sub matrix
so row 2 and column 2 that element is a
sub matrix
yeah so k of if so if you evaluate k on
the same element in two places that will
always be non-negative
so sub matrix doesn't mean any arbitrary
block
yeah so sub matrix means
means a matrix that you get by choosing
the same
set of indices for rows and columns
good question thank you
all right now we will represent this
in a more compact way where i will write
f to be the examples of the training set
and f star
as the function evaluation at the test
set
equal to normal of 0
and i will call this block
to be k of
x x
this block to be k of
x x star i guess we've been writing star
as a prefix
as a subscript then again k of
x star and x and k
of x star
x star
ok again so this is the same thing
that's written above
where we are looking at just those
those examples that are of our immediate
concern
so examples in the training set and
examples in the test set and this is
like um
you're marginalizing out all the other
infinitely many
examples that you know are not of
immediate concern
yes question
so colonel uh so the question is do
kernels
act as some kind of a similarity metric
in general or is it only in the case of
gaussian processes
the answer is kernels always act as some
kind of a similarity metric
and you can use any kernel
and come up with a covariance matrix for
a gaussian process
there's no limitation of which kernels
you can or cannot use as long as it's a
valid kernel
that can serve as a covariance function
for for a covariance matrix
for a gaussian process
exactly the reason is because a kernel
can be interpreted as
a dot product in some higher dimensional
feature space and
dot products are a good you know
similarity metric
so to speak all right
ah was there another question
right so we started with an infinite
dimensional
functional space and then marginalized
out
every example that is not of immediate
concern to
reduce ourselves to a gaussian gaussian
distribution a multivariate gaussian
distribution over the set of
training and test examples all right
and with that we are almost there
once we are in vector land
from process land you know all our
properties
that we just reviewed can now be
directly applied so these properties
that we covered conditioning marginal
conditioning especially this is you know
you need to be able to invert the matrix
right so this this is where we are
dealing with finite dimensions here
right so ah we got the f
vector to be this and in general our y
vector our
y we saw was f of x
plus noise
where it so happened conveniently that
the noise was also
gaussian discriminant gaussian followed
a gaussian distribution
and we're going to use the summation
property to add these two
right so we get y y star
equals f f star
plus epsilon epsilon stars
and this is now distributed as
normal distribution where the means of
f's were 0 the means of
our errors were 0 so we are still
at 0 here but the covariance matrix is
now
k of x x plus
sigma square i k
of x x star
k of x
x star and k of x star
x star plus sigma square i
right any questions in this so f
followed this distribution by
marginalizing out
all the examples that were not of
immediate concern
and by our
noise hypotheses that we have gaussian
noise in our observation
we get a distribution over the y's to be
f's plus the noise
and over here we are just using the
summation property and adding up the
covariances
epsilon the entire epsilon vector
follows normal 0 and
sigma square i right so you just add it
here it only adds along the diagonal
um and this is the
this is the matrix that we are going to
now work work with
and given this matrix we are just one
step away from
from finishing of the ocean processes
so so the probability of
y star given
y and
x star and x x and x star is kind of
implicit in in the indices that we have
chosen
is now
or another way to put it is
y star given y
x x star is distributed according to a
normal distribution
with some mean mu call it mu star
and some covariance sigma star
where the this mu and sigma star are
calculated according to
this conditioning rule we apply the
conditioning rule
to this mean and this covariance
and we get mu star
equals k of
x star comma x
times k of
x x
sigma square i
inverse y
and sigma star
equals k of x
star x star
plus sigma square i
minus k of x
star x
this is times
a of x x plus
sigma square inverse
k of x x star
this is a complex looking expression but
this is
exactly the same as this where we plug
in
k k x x in place of sigma a
k x star x star in place of sigma b b
and k of
k or rather k of x x plus sigma i
squared in place of
sigma a and so on right we're just
applying the conditioning rule
and we got our posterior predictive
distribution
right this is the posterior predictive
distribution of gaussian processes
yes question
yeah so over here um
this is just a short shorthand notation
for
the kernel matrix you get for evaluating
on that set of examples
so k k is so there is a one to one
relation between kernels and covariances
right covariance functions and kernel
functions there's a one to one
relationship
any kernel function can be used as a
covariance function
that's probably that's probably the most
important takeaway
from this class you know for you know in
general that kernel functions and
covariance functions are
are essentially the same
right so this is the posterior
predictive distribution for gaussian
processes
and the expression looks pretty complex
but
everything here is straightforward
linear algebra right there is
we have a set of x's we have the set of
x stars
um and and you know just compute this
and you get your posterior predictive
distribution
for the test examples nowhere here do we
have y
star that's important because we are you
know making predictions about y star
we only have y's x's and x stars
and given this ah in order to kind of
construct a good gp model
the most important
decision step or rather the only
decision step
is to come up with the right kernel
function or to come up with the right
covariance matrix right once you come up
with
the right covariance matrix there's
everything else is pretty much set in
stone right everything else just flows
along once you decide
once you choose what your kernel matrix
is there is no loss function there is no
gradient descent
there is no you know fitting of models
all that we do is given the set of x's
and y's in our training set
we just remember them choose a kernel
kernel function
and then wait for test examples once we
get a first test example
we plug it into this expression and
obtain a predictive distribution
right and because we covered this in
svms as well
and because this is a kernel based
method
a consequence of that is that we need to
remember our
training set all the way into test time
right and that is basically showing up
here because
you need to have the x's and wise from
your training set
in order to make the pos you know the uh
prediction
yes questions
so the uh the the result what we get
here is uh similar to a generative model
can you expand on that a little bit like
y given x
or in this case given everything
yeah the the fact that the posterior
ended up being a gaussian
is actually a property of gaussians
right we saw that
when you when you start with a a
distribution that is
gaussian and you condition on a few
variables what you end up with is also
gaussian so that's a property that is
kind of unique to the oceans
where you start with a multivariate
gaussian you marginalize out a few of
them
you still end up with a gaussian with a
smaller domain in a smaller dimensional
space you start with the gaussian
vector you condition on a few of them
you still get a gaussian with what's
remaining
right and and that's why the posterior
also is now is now gaussian
because we conditioned on the the y's
that we
that we observed in the training set and
why is this called
the reason why this is called
nonparametric is because
we did not come up with any kind of a
functional form
for our prediction function
isn't that a function
so mu star and sigma star are
well you can you can you can think of
them as a functional form
but what you will what you will realize
is that
there is there is uh there was no
fundamental limit on what these values
could have been
so next i'm going to show some
visualization that will probably give
you a better
better uh better hint of what why
this is called non-parametric maybe
maybe that might answer the question
let's
let's move on to some visualization
any other questions on this yes question
can we do the same thing for other
expansion families great great question
so so gaussian process is what's also
uh it's a type of a stochastic process
and if you're uh
if you're familiar with stochastic
processes stochastic process you can
think of them as
a collection of random variables with
with some kind of an index set
and this is a
gaussian process is essentially
a collection of random variables where
the index set is the domain of your
function
right and the
in theory you could do the same you know
go through the same exercise for any
other distribution
other than other than gaussians but the
other distributions
may not have uh first of all they may
not have multivariate versions
so for example a poisson distribution uh
you know there is no multivariate hassan
i mean you can have a collection of
poisson but there's no multivariate
version of it you can still have a
for example you still do have a poisson
process
but they don't have this
the nice properties that if you
condition on something
what remains is also is a poisson
process right but that's true only for
gaussian processes
but if you condition on something what
remains is still gaussian if you
marginalize out something what remains
is still gaussian
so i guess the question is um
now what if your data is distributed
according to some exponential family
right and over there the most common the
common approach
that you see is the f over here
instead of f being y directly so we
assumed
uh y is equal to f plus
epsilon right the most common thing to
do
is what there's going to be some
kind of
you can call it an activation function
or the g function
that you that we used in glms and you
can have
the natural parameter be distribute
according to gaussian you can you can do
something like this
right and your observations y will now
go through this
non-linear transformation
to to make the actual observations but
once you do this
you lose the conditioning ability right
in in gaussian processes because the
noise was additive
and the noise was also gaussian
we got the y's in a gaussian form again
right but if this is non-linear if it's
not a simple summation of two gaussians
your y's will no longer be normally
distributed and you you cannot do the
conditioning and so on
so so you you can do it in principle
but you don't get these simple
expressions
this question
is there
so the question is do these properties
do they hold for other exponential
families
yeah so these properties are very unique
to gaussian which is what makes gaussian
processes kind of
you know nice to work with right
and you may have actually also come
across you know especially if you have
some kind of a background in finance you
may have
come across uh like brownian motion and
and weiner processes
and basically uh um the way to connect
that with
with what we saw today is a wiener
process
or brownian motion
is a gp is a gaussian process
with k of say s comma t equal to
just min min of s comma t for this
particular choice of kernel you get the
wiener process
if you don't know what a veno process
you don't have to worry but if you're
you know if you have some
background in finance and you know you
know what's browning motion and we in a
process
it relates to what we saw today by this
particular choice of
uh kernel-made kernel function all right
let's do some visualization
where's my browser there you go
all right so this is uh
i see another cursor i don't know
all right so this is a web page that
i've kind of pre-loaded
it is from a website called distill.pub
uh i would highly encourage you to
visit this website there are great
articles um explaining things about
machine learning and i'm a big fan of it
and you probably too should be one um
anyway so this is uh they have some
really cool visualization of gaussian
processes
and i'm going to scroll all the way down
to the very last visualization
which is pretty cool oops
yeah over here right so this is some
kind of a functional space
an abstract functional space so the x
axis over here
is is our space of inputs it need not
necessarily be
you know just scalar real value think of
it as some abstract space
and now the moment we choose a kernel
so there are three choices of kernels
here an rbf kernel which is also called
the gaussian kernel
a periodic kernel and linear kernel so
once we choose an rbf kernel
you know this defines a prior on our
functional space
right and these these curves that we see
here are samples of functions drawn from
this
from this gaussian process prior right
and once we have this we can now observe
our training data and start conditioning
on them
so so if if you click over here it's
this means we have condition on this
particular
input in our training of having this
particular y value
and similarly as you keep conditioning
on things that we observe
right the posterior distribution of
our gp of our gaussian process you know
takes this form
what this essentially means is for any
test example that might have an x value
over here
gp if we marginalize out everything
everything everything else except that
single slice
right that's going to be our posterior
predictive distribution
for the new x star
right and this basically tells for
examples
for test examples in this region our
posterior predictive distribution
has a very small variance means we are
very confident of what those values
should be
whereas over here in regions where we
haven't seen much of training data
the prediction value will be pretty you
know
pretty broad in the sense we'll have
very high variance we are less confident
about making predictions
in this region where there weren't much
training examples nearby
as opposed to here where the prediction
the posterior distributions have very
small variants which means we are making
very tight
or confident predictions this question
so when you march
so so back to the question does this
look like over fitting
right so um so this is like a
fundamental trade-off between parametric
and non-parametric models right
non-parametric models are extremely
flexible in the sense
if your data follows some pattern your
function your posterior distribution in
gps will follow that pattern
right and there is a common criticism
that non-parametric models can overfit
pretty easily but in in cases where you
have a reasonable amount of data you
know
non-parametric models tend to work
pretty well this this
this might look like over fitting and i
guess
that's you know as they say eyes in the
light it lies in the eye of the beholder
you might call this over fitting but
overfitting is is a loose
concept in general it's hard to kind of
give a formal definition of what
overfitting means
and you you could you could call it over
fitting but
you know um for example
uh if you use a different
kernel it would look like this
now you uncondition you get
now this is the prior and these are
samples from
the gray lines or samples from that gp
prior and as we start observing training
data
we're basically just conditioning and
these are
the the the pink band is basically
represents uh some i guess 95
range of the posterior distribution and
without conditioning it's
like the 95 range of the prior
distribution
right or you could use a combination of
the two compose the two kernels
and get something like this
what does that mean yeah so
you can construct kernels by taking
existing kernels and
kind of composing them you'll see some
of that in your homework homework too
you'll probably do some
kernel composition um as long you know
any function that
that uh that obeys the properties of you
know a kernel is is a kernels and you
can take existing kernels and
compose them with certain rules and
still get valid kernels
right so this this this is i think of a
a pretty pretty intuitive and a nice
visualization
of gaussian process where you start with
the prior
the choice of the kernel gives you
different priors
right just the choice of the kernel
without observing any data
right you choose different kernels you
get different priors the choice of the
kernel gives you
a different gp prior and depending on
the choice
of the kernel that you've chosen
observing data gives you different kinds
of
posterior gp posteriors
right this is a gp posterior if you use
a different curve
right and a test time to repeat
you know your test example will lie on
the on the horizontal axis at some point
and your predictive distribution is
going to be the
the vertical slice or or you know
marginalize out
everything else and and that's going to
be like the uh
gaussian distribution whose mean follows
the red thick line
and the the the like the the border
lines kind of define the
uh the the uh 95
range of that gaussian distribution yes
question
and you are asked to implement this like
an algorithm
how would you choose
yeah so uh the question i guess is when
do you
use the gaussian process right and um
the the answer is going to be pretty
boring as for
almost all answers in machine learning
see what works well on a
cross validation set right it sounds it
and that is probably the most pragmatic
answer and that should be the answer you
should always
go with uh always see any change that
you do how well does the performance
you know what what kind of performance
you get on a cross validation site
yes there was another question
yeah so the heat map on the right is
showing uh uh
this is like the kernel kernel matrix
the kernel matrix that you get by
conditioning on
on or the covariance matrix that you get
so in the posterior predictive
distribution
uh we ended up with a mean and a
covariance so this is like
i think this is the posterior covariance
this question is the choice
yeah so the question is um should the
choice of kernel
also be something that works well on
cross-validation and the answer is yes
and there are also techniques with which
you can learn a kernel
we didn't cover it today but the book
that i refer to the gaussian process for
machine learning it gives you a good
overview of how you can even learn
kernels from data
right not just hand craft them
yes question
so can composition of kernels be
interpreted as composition of two
functions
with two inputs in general no i wouldn't
think of it that way
it's just that you get a different
kernel
all right ah that's about it for today